and let's go out to new york and have a
conversation with matt matt good
afternoon how can
chrissy and i help uh good afternoon a
pleasure to talk to you guys
uh so i'm about to graduate from college
uh
i have a job with secured with a 70 000
salary okay
and i'm gonna graduate with uh thirty
thousand dollars with that okay
so i already have eight thousand dollars
saved up now i want to like attack this
debt but uh the issue is
my car that i currently use and i'm
gonna have to use for my job
uh it's uh kind of 20 years old and uh
i suspect it's about to die in the next
year or so
so how do i like balance between like
making sure i have enough cash on hand
to like get a new car
or a new used car and uh attacking out
of debt
all right so you have eight thousand
dollars in a savings right
right okay cool and you're saying you
think
the car is going to die in a year right
yeah there's nothing like like
specifically wrong with it but those
things just have been going wrong with
it uh
recently and uh yeah yeah i'm just
concerned about it's
longevity yeah i'll get you you ain't
concerned about the car because i think
i think you're concerned because you got
the money you want to go buy a newer car
um if nothing is going wrong with the
car right now this is what i want you to
do
i want you to take seven thousand
dollars of that and i want you to put it
towards your 30
000 of debt right now your student loans
then
what i want you to do if you start
seeing issues with your car
okay and it starts starts to have some
issues i mean some serious issues too
matt
i'm not talking about you know you think
you heard something so now you need a
card
like no it's not working it it's broke
it's not drivable
then i have no problem with you pausing
paying off this thirty thousand dollars
but how old are you right now matt uh
i'm 21.
yeah yeah yeah matt so i want you to
knock out this debt
this year okay if you can be really get
gazelle focus get intense get a purpose
get
driven you can pay off the debt this
year you're making 70 000 on there how
do you do something on the side to
generate another 20 000
this year so if you can pay off your
debt this year
then next year you can focus on saving
up cash to go buy you
a real nice quality used car so what i'm
going to say for you right now
is don't worry about um purchasing a new
car right now because you said nothing's
wrong with the car
right now great i would take it to the
shop maybe get it tuned up a little bit
you can take some of your eight thousand
dollars to do that
and get a good fresh get a good oil
change maybe some good new tires on
there
um then from there put the rest onto
your debt and just
just attack the debt then next year
let's go ahead and start the process of
saving
yeah my advice is so similar to a call
we had a little bit earlier anthony that
i would say
you're about to get this job where
you're making 75 000 a year
you need to pretend like you're not yes
you need to pretend like you're making
25 000 a year and because if not it's
going to be oh my gosh this new
big exciting amount of money oh i can
live a little more comfortably
i can slow down on my debt snowball or
my student loans or
like anthony said need this car and
there is some you do need a car
at some point and so that's why you need
to stay serious live on way
less than you make have that margin to
take all that extra towards your student
loan towards the car whenever you need
it
and then after that you can get a little
bit more comfortable after you get your
savings up and all that kind of stuff
but i just don't want you to take your
foot off the gas because you've got
a lot more money than you're used to
having which will be easy to do so keep
that intensity even though you're making
more money now
absolutely matt and man and listen man
you're doing things right
yeah you're 21 years old making about 70
75 000
you know the average income in america
right now is right around 48 to 54
000 depending on what part you're in so
you're ahead of the average person in
america
so now let's go ahead and get strategic
let's go ahead and think about what can
we do
to really set yourself up to be
successful down the road and that is pay
off all your debt
get a fully funded emergency fund and so
you do live in new york so i know the
prices up there are a little bit more
expensive so
you're going to be a little creative but
here's the main thing
chris this is what i tell everyone
especially young people um
you know when they're so young and when
they are ahead of the game a little bit
get a clear why get a clear vision
and if you get a clear why a clearer
vision then it's going to be very easy
for you to do the things that you have
to do to be successful
but if you don't have a clear why clear
vision then you'll have
those kind of questions well should i do
this should i do that but when you have
a clear why
there's a clear answer that you need to
take to get to your wife not only that
but that clear why is going to help you
avoid
the short-term temporary distractions
of the bag or whatever apparently i'm
the old people because you're like a bag
or more money i was like what does a bag
mean i guess i'm in the old
look all the young people are laughing
i'm like
i'm learning things from ao today
learning things
anyway that y will help you resist those
distractions and stay focused